climate change activist greta toonberg
arriving at youth cop a u.n climate
change meeting in milan
a slightly reluctant celebrity although
comfortable enough to give a defiant and
dismissive speech about the failure of
politicians to tackle global warming
build back better blah blah blah green
economy blah blah blah these words will
ring in the ears of world leaders as
they gather for the next major climate
summit being held in glasgow later this
year known as cop26
and tunburg along with ugandan activist
vanessa nakate had some harsh criticism
for the country in charge
the united kingdom is the host of cop 26
in glasgow later this year but it
continues to grant new licenses to
extract oil and gas in the north sea
does that dent its moral authority in
your view i'll say that's a textbook
example of hypocrisy the uk is very good
at creating carbon accounting
um
excluding emissions and etc etc so it's
very easy at them to to make it seem
like they are taking
leadership and it's i find it very
strange that
they're like they are the ones who we
are supposed to look up to now
but they are
objectively one of the biggest climate
villains
do you think of the united kingdom as a
climate villain
i think they are because true climate
leadership
doesn't mean opening new core parlance
or funding new oil fields true climate
leadership is
prioritizing the people and the planet
over profits do you
accept that
we are
in the hands of politicians right now
and they operate in a world where they
think about what is possible not what is
perfect a report by the un showed that
the global emissions are expected to
rise by 16
compared to 2010 levels by 2030. i mean
that says it all we think that we are
moving in the right direction but the
emissions are actually still increasing
so we are not doing the right thing
whatever they are doing they are doing
it wrong have you given up on them
well i haven't given up on them because
if i give up it means communities like
mine will continue to face the worst of
the climate crisis
bound up as it is in politics and
realism cop 26 in glasgow is unlikely to
meet the high ideals of the youth
climate movement
they may not have given up but they
probably will be disappointed
hannah thomas peter sky news in milan